in Okayama Japan locals celebrate a
legendary and phibian the Japanese giant
salamander once faced extinction due to
hunting and habitat destruction now it's
making a comeback most species of
salamanders and their close relatives
the newts average just a few inches in
length like this palm sized fire belly
but Japanese giant salamanders can grow
up to five feet in length and weigh 36
kilograms that's 80 pounds known in
Japanese as the Osan show or pepper fish
the salamander is entirely aquatic and
nocturnal that during the day these shy
creatures burrow into the riverbanks to
hide it's a relic of the species this
animal has hardly changed for the past
20 million years judging by its ancient
appearance that's not hard to believe
authorities have outlawed hunting the
creature but its habitat is still at
risk the hustle and bustle of modern
Japan is hardly ideal for a giant and
tibia more than 125 million people live
in this nation of small islands and land
is at an absolute premium but the real
threat to the salamander is here dams
created to control flooding Kyoto gets
an average of 64 inches of rain a year
much of it during the monsoon season a
network of dams and flood gates prevent
the city from getting waterlogged but
they are a barrier to the lifecycle of
the giant salamanders herpetologist dr.
Akira Mori is working on a solution
tomo imagine de ichiban Latoya Morano
Kasane Koji Tokido Sunoco CC no tameni
pour massive in solar Tokarev on oh damn
it screw em to expect a no stotra Sancho
no naka de Barcelona crustacean
electrons
in this rare night footage a giant
salamander struggles back upstream after
becoming trapped in a dam spillway when
the banks of rivers are covered in
concrete for flood control the
salamanders habitat is destroyed so
yamato-san Lanson ambassador's desk
already know so you you were all FINA
you are no external schema coconut not
dissimilar Sunland Inc name to combat
the problem akira Mori and his
colleagues at Kyoto University have
devised a complex system of ramps and
staircases to modify the dams they allow
the giant salamanders to maneuver
upriver beyond the dams and back to the
mountain streams where they can lay
their eggs and continue their species
zoos worldwide have had some success
breeding the Japanese giant salamander
in captivity the Japan hopes that by
creating a shortcut around the dams it
will allow these giants to flourish in
their natural habitat as well
sponsored by National Geographic mission
programs taking science and exploration
into the new millennium